des impôts demain à toujours rester la
france on a une évolution démographique
dans le continent africain qui voit sa
population doubler
on a des flux migratoires qui avant vous
craignez le grenat sont aujourd'hui des
campements on a des campagnes qui
s'installent dans les rues de paris
on a cette situation aux frontières
d'extrême tension donc il faut agir il
faut dire que donc aujourd'hui nous
devons dire globalement qu'il y a trop
de flux migratoires on a battu tous les
records l'année dernière 400 mille
étrangers en situation illégale
sans parler de ceux qui sont arrivés en
situation illégale sont arrivés dans
notre pays à ce rythme ça veut dire plus
de deux millions sur le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron alors bien sûr le
débat il est nécessaire il est utile
qu'est ce que j'aurais préféré qu'ils un
vote à la sortie qu'est ce que vous en
attendez je rappelle quand même qu'on a
voté la loi zee l'immigration c'était
l'année dernière parce qu'il ya quinze
ans sans aucun résultat
emmanuel macron lui même a dit que cette
loi était décevante
on l'avait dénoncé à l'assemblée
nationale parce que c'étaient des
mesures là aussi les artificiers